[Musique]
r
mais
coût
thil le coup ne sait rien
il n'est pas
tous
je vais
mais en cours
[Musique]
des mots
amour
sept jours
sacrée qu'une chose
ça
et
et ton truc
[Musique]
il
de données
toujours
la cour
st
c'est
moi
avi
la maladie
je mets
[Musique]
imedi
j'aime les serres
l'enjeu 100 ans
mon coeur
[Musique]
oui je suis un artiste
je n'ai pas un métier conventionnelle je
suis à l'auteur de boxe c'est un métier
difficile
il y a des hauts et des bas mais c'est
celui que j'ai choisi et c'est pour la
vie à l'âge de 7 ans j'ai trouvé un
prospectus qui annonçaient un concours
de chant pour enfants et j'ai voulu y
participer
ma maman bienveillante m'a déconseillé
d'y aller elle m'a dit tu risques de
perdre et tu vas pleurer
je lui ai répondu maman si je perds je
vais sûrement pleurer quelques jours
mais si tu m'empêche d'y aller je
pleurerais toute ma vie alors mes
parents vit en moi une certaine
détermination déjà tout petit
ils m'ont accompagné et j'ai remporté le
premier prix un cahier de coloriage
alors il y avait bien quelques requins
dans la salle prêt à faire de l'argent
sur ma petite frimousse mais mes parents
ont voulu me protéger ils se sont dit si
elle a un rêve on va l'aider à le
réaliser
mon père était imprimeur ma mère mère au
foyer
c'est enfin quand même ils se sont dit
on va l'emmener en studio on va
enregistrer les chansons et puis si ça
marche tant mieux si ça marche pas ça
nous fera un bon souvenir
alors quand je suis arrivé dans ses
studios personne n'aurait pu imaginer
qu'elle allait naître en moi une réelle
vocation et même un métier on a envoyé
ce disque un petit peu partout aux
médias et j'ai été immédiatement appelés
pour chanter dans toute la france
à la télévision et à la radio et puis
avait cette émission pour enfants que
j'ai regardé tous les mercredis matins
émerveiller avec mes dessins animés
préférés
salut les p'tits loups sur la première
chaîne française
on m'avait invité à chanter dans ma
chance dans mon émission préférée
et puis la productrice charmé par le
petit bout en train que j'étais m'a
proposé de chanter le générique de
l'émission et peu de temps après d'en
devenir l'animatrice jeux présentés donc
indirecte de trois heures tous les
mercredis matin sur la première chaîne
française
je vous ai apporté un petit extrait
regarder
[Musique]
ok
bissonnet une semaine voir ça de plus
près avec la météo aujourd'hui d'ouest
en est
ça met la force
et la province seront d'épargné c'était
génial
j'avais même durant un cours de
géographie en même temps alors justement
en parlant des cols j'ai dû arrêter le
système scolaire classique pour prendre
des cours par correspondance
et puis j'ai commencé à avoir une vie
original une vie très différente une vie
d'adulte
j'avais des responsabilités il fallait
que j'apprenne des dizaines de pages de
textes toutes les semaines
j'avais des répétitions le mercredi
matin il fallait que je sois à partir de
6h sur les plateaux pour me faire
habiller me faire maquiller et être
prête pour ce direct de trois heures et
puis je vivais dans des palaces parce
que j'avais ma carrière de chanteuse en
parallèle j'ai fait 7 45 pour un album
je faisais des tournées en france mais
même à l'international jusqu'au japon
et puis je me souviens de
du festival de cannes où j'avais été
invitée du carnaval de nice où je
chantais devant une foule dont je ne
voyais pas le bout et puis il y avait
les gardes du corps au sikkim
attendaient à la sortie je ne pouvais
plus marcher dans la rue sans signer
d'autographes
alors je pensais à ce moment là que
c'était vraiment pour la vie vous savez
dans une tête d'enfant on peut pas
imaginer une fin on a pas d'angoissé à
ce moment là on se dit juste voilà je
suis chanteuse je suis comédienne et je
ferai ça toute ma vie
et d'ailleurs il y avait les journaux
qui titrait orly lâche sur les thèmes
paul médine france cette actrice
américaine qui avait une très très
grande carrière alors je me voyais déjà
comme elles suivent cette grande
carrière et puis arrivé à l'âge de 13
ans c'est la chute
le chômage
oui moi qui avait été homologué dans le
livre guinness des records en tant que
la plus jeune animatrice de télévision
je m'apprêtais à battre un nouveau
record celui de la plus jeune chômeuse
de france alors sur le coup j'ai pas
compris ce qui m'arrivait la petite
fille qui avait été adulé pendant toutes
ces années se retrouver plongée dans
l'anonymat
et puis je me suis demandé comment
j'allais pouvoir faire parce que moi je
ne voulais être ni avocat ni médecin ma
vie était sur scène j'ai perdu le goût
pour les études et je me suis dit bon je
fais je vais travailler je vais trouver
une solution pour retrouver sur scène je
vais monter une entreprise tiens
pourquoi pas une entreprise
d'événementiel
c'est vrai avec une agence artistique je
pourrais moi même me produis remonter
sur scène présenter des événements
j'avais vu des gens faire ça je trouvais
ça super je me suis dit voilà si les
médias ne veulent plus de moi c'est pas
grave je vais me trouver du travail tout
seul
le problème c'est que j'avais pas
d'argent alors il a fallu que je
travaille
et puis alors que les autres adolescents
avaient des préoccupations de leur âge
moi ma préoccupation c'était revenir sur
scène c'est tout alors je me souviens
que j'ai travaillé dans cet atelier un
atelier de routage ou
on envoyait des courriers en grand
nombre et je coller des étiquettes sur
des enveloppes
alors pour y trouver le côté positif je
me suis dit tiens on va y mettre du
rythme et je suis devenue la plus rapide
à coller ces étiquettes sur les
enveloppes et je me disais que plus
j'étais rapide et plus vite j'allais
arriver vers la création de mon
entreprise
ce que j'ai fait j'ai commencé à chanter
à présenter des événements
c'était fantastique je gagnais très bien
ma vie et puis au bout d'un moment j'ai
commencé à en avoir marre marre
d'entendre le bruit des fourchettes des
gens qui étaient en train de manger
pendant que pendant que je chantais gens
qui je m'entendais même pas chanter
et puis je chantais des chansons des
autres et puis j'avais pas vraiment mon
répertoire puis je savais plus ce que
j'étais en train de faire vraiment j'ai
pas mal galéré et à l'âge de 26 ans
mon entourage toujours très bienveillant
m'a dit que j'étais fini que j'étais
trop vieille pour faire ce métier
alors là j'ai pris encore une claque
on m'a dit qu'il fallait que je trouve
un travail normal que je me marie que
j'ai des enfants et que j'entre dans le
moule
un travail normal
comment on fait pour trouver un travail
normal quand on n'a qu'un seul diplôme
en poche celui de la plus jeune
animatrice de télévision
je ne savais pas qu'ils allaient
m'embaucher avec ça alors j'ai pas
accepté de me résigner
je me suis dit orly on va pas venir
taper à ta porte
si tu veux continuer à faire ce métier
il va falloir que toi tu ailles taper
aux portes
alors je me suis souvenu de mes sept ans
de cette détermination et de ce concours
auquel j'ai voulu participer et ça m'a
ramené à chercher des auditions il y
avait cette petite annonce dans un
journal qui annonçait qu'on recherchait
pour la grande musique comédie musicale
internationale le roi lion cette comédie
musicale qui était jouée à broadway et
un petit peu partout dans le monde
recherchés pour rechercher ces nouveaux
talents pour la comédie musicale qui
était en train de se jouer à ce moment
là en bout rond mais je me suis dit peu
importe je vais y aller alors
l'annoncent disait aussi qu'il
recherchait des noirs des métis et des
gens qui chantaient du gospel tout à
fait moi
non sans rire je savais que je savais
pas je savais que c'est pas vraiment
pour moi mais je me suis dit c'est pas
grave c'est une grande production
peut-être que delà du roi lion ils vont
me dire c'est pas bon pour elle on va
lui faire faire mamma mia j'en sais rien
alors j'y suis allé je me suis présenté
et puis j'avais tous ses détracteurs qui
me disait cette petite voix vous savez
qu'on entends je suis sûr que ça vous
est déjà arrivé à vous quand vous avez
envie de faire quelque chose de grand et
puis tout à coup vous entendez ces
petits démons qui vous disent non c'est
pas pour toi tu y arriveras pas de tes
trop vieille n'était pas assez bonne tu
as plus de talent c'est pas bon et ben
je les ai entendus alors au début ça m'a
un petit peu freiné j'y suis allée à
reculons
et puis tout à coup j'ai quelque chose
qui est monté en moins ces mêmes
détracteurs m'ont donné la force de me
présenter devant les membres du jury
lorsque j'ai chanté i'm so excited ils
se sont mis à danser sur leurs chaises
alors à partir de ce moment là à passer
un j'ai passé un long processus
d'audition avec des textes à apprendre
c'était en anglais il y avait des textes
et avait des chansons fallait jouer la
comédie il y avait des auditions de
danse etc
j'ai fait ça pendant plusieurs jours
mais bon j'avais toujours le le courage
jusqu'au moment on est venu me voir et
m'a dit orly félicitations tu as réussi
tu vas participer à l'audition finale en
allemand oui alors je ne parlais pas un
mot d'allemand
c'est quand l'audition dans quinze jours
oui bien sûr oui alors je suis reparti
avec mon script et là je me suis dit bon
on en lit comment faire et bien tout
simplement faire mon père nous a
toujours dit à tous les enfants
faites ce que vous voulez mais faites le
bien alors j'ai voulu bien faire j'ai
pris un professeur des cours de
phonétique la traduction du texte pour
bien interpréter bien interpréter la
chanson
et puis je suis arrivé à nouveau devant
les membres du jury à hambourg j'ai dit
mon texte la chanson etc
et au bout de quinze jours j'ai eu la
réponse un contrat de trois ans pour la
comédie musicale le roi lion
je vais chanter sur des musiques dette
belton jaune devant deux mille trois
cents personnes huit fois par semaine
double chooz le 5
et le dimanche et là c'est la
renaissance
ça y est je suis revenu sous les
projecteurs et qu'elle projecteurs
quelle scène plus de 50 artistes des
musiciens des chanteurs qui ont été
auditionnés dans plus de 20 pays
et là moi orly
la petite fille que je croyais qu'ils
avaient perdu son talent se retrouve au
milieu de ce casse est exceptionnel ça y
est j'ai réussi et puis vous imaginez
que trois ans ça représente plus de 1000
spectacles mille fois je suis monté sur
scène mille fois j'ai chanté les mêmes
chansons j'ai dit le même texte
alors oui c'était formidable mais
j'avais envie de passer à autre chose
et puisque j'avais réussi ça je pouvais
aussi réussir autre chose alors je me
suis lancé un nouveau défi je me suis
dit tiens
j'adore la musique latine alors ce que
je pourrais faire par exemple c'est
partir à cuba
apprendre à danser la salsa et à parler
espagnol serait génial alors j'arrive à
cuba bienvenue à la havane
et là je m'imagine tous les clichés
qu'on m'avait dit jusque là alors qu
basse et les mojitos le cigare dès qu'on
arrive à l'aéroport on se met à danser
la salsa
eh bien pas du tout alors là j'arrive et
puis c'est la claque je tombe devant la
réalité en fait qu basse et c'est plein
de joie de vivre mais pour des gens qui
ont beaucoup de difficultés alors il ya
des ya des manques de tous à cuba par
exemple moi j'ai vécu dans des immeubles
où il y avait de l'eau 30 minutes par
jour où on célébrait l'arrivée de
l'électricité par des cris de joie et
gaulle à l'osm au ckc supermarché où il
y avait rien à manger et plein de gens
qui disaient on peut pas vivre ici et
ben moi l'européenne tout à coup
j'arrive et je dis moi je vais virage
veut vivre à cuba
je veux vivre cette aventure
exceptionnelle et d'ailleurs à cuba j'ai
découvert ma nouvelle identité musicale
ça y est je ne savais pas quoi faire
jusque là eh bien je vais chanter de la
musique latine et puis ça ressemblait à
ça
[Musique]
si vous
je ne sais pas
l'essai
ma
c'est certain
non
ma
[Musique]
ok
oh
ma
[Musique]
à
m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci j'ai là sur la chance aujourd'hui
d'être accompagné par un cubain a mis
depuis 11 ans et retrait gallinacés pas
fait alors voilà j'ai vécu à cube up en
ont six ans et je voulais à cuba aussi
être chanteuse alors qu'est ce que j'ai
fait j'ai demandé un permis de travail
que j'ai obtenue après au bout de deux
longues années
et puis je suis rapidement devenue une
des chanteuses les plus populaires de
cuba merci c'était incroyable cette
aventure j'ai commencé à avoir mes
propres concerts avec mes chansons
j'ai chanté avec de grands artistes
comme par exemple omara portuondo qui
est la diva du buena vista du buena
vista social club
et puis j'en parle avec beaucoup
d'émotion comme vous voyez et c'est un
exemple cette femme puisque elle a
chanté toute sa vie c'était l'âge de 66
ans qu'elle est devenue célèbre alors
vous pensez bien que on a tous
l'occasion et le temps de faire
d'arriver au bout de ses rêves
et puis donc j'ai fait j'ai fait tous
ces concerts j'ai fait des vidéoclips
fantastique j'ai fait des émissions
radio et télé j'ai retrouvé la célébrité
que j'avais quand j'étais petit je me
suis rendu compte que finalement c'était
pas c'est important que le plus
important pour moi c'était d'avoir un
public de chanter de les avoir en face
de moi de donner de l'énergie et d'en
recevoir
alors
après avoir eu cette maturité artistique
mais aussi cette paix intérieure j'ai pu
retourner aux sources
j'ai quitté cuba je suis parti en israël
le pays où je suis né et que mes parents
ont quitté alors que je n'avais qu'un
nom et je me suis dit je prenais pas la
langue de ce pays j'en connais pas
vraiment la culture
je suis plus cubaine qu'israélienne
alors si à cuba j'ai chanté deux
chansons israélienne sur des rythmes
salsa
pourquoi j'irais pas en israël chanter
des chansons cubaines et leur apporter
l'expérience que j'avais vécu là bas
alors je fais ça depuis je suis en
israël je j'ai mon propre concept j'ai
des concerts où je chante mes trois
patrie la france israël et cuba je
partage la joie de vivre qui m'anime
depuis le jour où j'ai connu cette terre
fantastique et je remercie les cubains
pour ça et donc je partage avec elle
tout mon public aujourd'hui l'histoire
que je vous ai raconté en musique
j'espère que mon histoire va inspirer
d'autres personnes et qu'elle les
incitera sortir de leur zone de confort
et oser passer à l'action et les fois où
vous trouvez que la vie est difficile et
parfois même en juste souvenez vous que
la villa et son carnaval
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
non
m
[Musique]
c
non